let's bring in congressman dan crenshaw
uh the republican from texas
congressman we just got rid of the war
powers act excuse me we got rid of the
declaration allowed us to have the war
in iraq
so means uh that is no longer it's no
longer allowed constitutionally for the
president to take shots without telling
us
right well it's a bit more complicated
than that because uh the war powers act
uh does still exist
the president always has the right to
take action to defend
u.s troops so i believe i didn't see
exactly what authorizations they were
referencing for for this particular
strike but
um it could have been uh the the 2001
aumf it could have been war powers
uh because what's happening is these
shia militias look they're constantly
poking the bear
and they're they're used drones to do so
they use increasingly advanced drones
uh they want to create conflict they're
trying to create conflict in the kurdish
region
and they're trying to get conflict with
us in the hopes that we would leave
because in the end they just want to
take over iraq uh
so look the striking uh
did this strike and near al-qaim that uh
killed five um
iranian-backed shia militia groups uh
it's a good thing especially especially
if you're going to
be talking about trying to enter into a
new uh
nuclear deal with iran okay which i
think we should be very skeptical of but
if you're going to do that
at least at least do it with leverage at
least do it
showing them that they should be on
notice and that we won't that we will
not give an inch
um and that we will not let the the
sovereignty of iraq be violated by
iranian proxies right congressman i know
the hhs secretary is going to go visit
fort bliss
that migrant facility today and there
are now reports of migrant youth being
subjected to rampant disease
sexual abuse some are on suicide watch
kamala harris was there on friday
but she didn't visit fort bliss and she
didn't visit
the donna facility where a lot of people
were saying that's where the big problem
is that's where she should have gone
your reaction yeah it's pretty obvious
kamal harris does not care about this
issue i think it's rather obvious that
she only went to
to visit um in a you know where there
was a convenient airport
where she could do a quick photo op say
she did it because she was sick of
getting made fun of
by conservative media that she never
went but she's not going to actually
take any action
um look when it comes to these
facilities they're they're overcrowded
they're overwhelmed
okay so we and and we can wring our
hands trying to figure out what to do
with that but we don't have new ones
uh just to build right off the bat so we
have to look at the source of the
problem
and the source of the problem is the
binded administration because they
reversed
policies that were in place that was
limiting the flow okay they reversed the
remaining mexico policy
they reversed asylum cooperation asylum
cooperation agreements
with the northern triangle countries and
they refused to tackle the biggest issue
now the biggest issue is that we can't
legally hold migrant families or minors
past 21 days so we can't adjudicate
these claims
this would be the simplest fix and it
has to be a legislative fix it has to
come from congress
and all we have to do is increase that
number of days
increase the number of immigration
judges adjudicate these claims
make the process go faster you know what
that avoids it avoids this catch and
release program
right which which means that there's
less incentives to just jump across the
border
this stuff is easy to fix and i think
that's why it's so infuriating
that the democrats don't want to and you
have to question their motives here
why don't they want to well they want
more illegal immigration
okay they like the crisis that's why
they don't want to solve it there's
really no other way to
to explain this you know something else
we've been talking about in addition to
the
crisis at our southern border although
they don't call it a crisis they say
uh the strategy is working uh something
else that we've been talking about
is critical race theory crt being taught
in america's schools
and you know a lot of parents are
learning during the pandemic they're
they're looking over their kid's
shoulder and they're seeing what the
kids were learning and they're horrified
at it and that's why we see all the
protests at different school boards
across the country but in addition to in
the schools
it is being taught and talked about in
the military and i know you
have asked whistleblowers to come
forward and tell you
uh examples of this i think you've heard
from 400 so far
what are you going to do with their
testimony
yeah we've heard from hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds i think we
we tend to say that there's over 400
credible ones but you know there's many
many more than that
and look we're going to keep we're going
to keep exposing this we're going to
keep posting it
and um here's a couple examples that
we've already posted
uh one air force command was was making
their
making their troops go through
privileged walks okay
implying that if you're white if you're
male that you're more privileged than
somebody else so
what this is is it's a crt theory but
it's manifest in sort of this
anti-racism
training all of this stuff is connected
with intersectionality theory
all of these things but but the but the
primary the primary thread that links
them all together
is this america institutions are
inherently racist
the liberal order should be challenged
the liberal order the liberal definition
of equality
should be challenged and replaced with
a new order where you see everything
through race this is how you get to race
quotas this is how you get to this
to this this teaching of anti-racism
which which tells white people that
they're an oppressor
no matter what they've done they must be
an oppressor and that if you're a
minority you're you're oppressed
this is this is the basic idea behind
critical race theory
it results in extremely divisive
divisive outcomes people now seeing each
other as an other
as opposed to a simply another teammate
wearing the same uniform with the same
mission it's very dangerous
i thought general milley totally missed
the point last week
he says well i read now and i reached
out that's nothing to do with it
you know we read we read mind confidence
school no one thought we were nazis that
was part of the curriculum
you find out about other things in other
insurgency we get it
that's nothing to do with with critical
race theory is
and the privileged walks is an example
of that i mean if you were there to
question them
you probably would have been able to get
them back on track and say that has
nothing to do with
critical race theory well what i would
have told him is you might teach
maoism in the context of that it killed
tens of millions of people so if you're
gonna teach crt
teach it as if two people are debating
it right teach it that way but what's
really happened
happening is that it's being
propagandized and when you have a you
have a seminar
at west point called whiteness and white
rage and it is taught by a
professor who has in the past written
that that
that white republicans want a white
supremacist country
i'm sorry that's one-sided that's not
just teaching for education that's not
just teaching
for the sake of situational awareness
don't give me that
that's just racist nonsense is actually
what's being taught and it's being
propagandized so no i i vehemently
disagree
with his point there this isn't being
taught in some good faith way
you know it and it shouldn't we can't go
down this path where
see some liberals are just so open to
everything right now they're not ever
open to everything they're open to what
they like
but in the end they stand for nothing
and that's the problem with that sort of
openness
and you have to stand for something and
you have to stand for classic liberal
american
values that's what you have to stand for
that's what our country is based on
those values are not racist they are not
oppressive
they are they are they are how we have
become the most prosperous country the
most successful country in the history
of
the world and we have to we have to
stand by that truth instead of
instead of trying to undercut it with
these propagandizing
seminars being put into our military
institutions dan what was your reaction
to
i mean you fought for our country to the
olympic hammer thrower gwen berry she
turned her back on the flag during the
anthem
and she also put a black t-shirt over
her face that said
uh activist athlete
we don't need any more activist athletes
i you know she should be removed from
the team
the entire point of the olympic team is
to represent the united states of
america
that's the entire point okay so you know
it's it's one thing when these nba
players do it okay fine we'll just stop
watching
but now the olympic team and it's it's
multiple cases of this
they they should be removed that should
be the bare minimum requirement is that
you
is that you believe in the country
representing but look taking it a couple
levels deeper
this is this is the pathology that
occurs
when we when we're teaching critical
race theory um
into our institutions because critical
race theory again
basically teaches that our institutions
are racist
that our systems are deeply racist now
you can't see the racism right because
it's subtle
but the only and if you deny it it's
because of your white fragility
but you're teaching people this
constantly and this is what it results
in it results in this
in in these displays of hatred towards
our own country
and it's got to stop daniel what would
have happened to you when you were
in the military standing in formation
and attention
during the national anthem and you
turned away from the flag
well it's a good question the
unfortunate answer these days
is i bet it would be allowed these days
it would just be fine
now now you might be now you might gain
a lot of disrespect from your teammates
because look
the broad consensus amongst the troops
the people actually doing the war
fighting is that america's still a good
place and we love our flag and we love
our anthem
and we love to fight for our military
okay but but
but the problem going on in the military
now is that there's more of an incentive
to turn away from the flag to say
something woke than there is to fight
against it that's
that's the truth you mean like the rest
of the country
right you know i'll never forget like
just uh
about eight months ago there was a there
was a seal who was
you know trying to transition into a
different different gender
and he goes on anderson cooper and
politicizes this goes on anderson cooper
as an active duty seal and then instead
of
instead of the seal admiral saying look
we don't let our people go on the news
and talk about their politics or about
or about their agenda like this instead
he says we fully support this person
fully support them in every capacity now
i'm not sure why you would say that
considering that if you're transitioning
you are therefore undeployable
you know okay so we just put millions of
dollars into training you you have this
you have this surgical transition you're
no longer deployable we can't use you
anymore
so i don't know why on earth we would
say we support that but that's the
incentive structure that's in place
so so look we've been looking at this
problem for a while now people are like
oh it's just because biden's president
no no no
we were looking at this while trump was
president too this started the start of
then
it's gotten much much worse now that's
why we did the whistleblower project
and that's why we're receiving hundreds
of these complaints that we're just
going to keep
promoting until the dod comes out with
policy
that says this stuff is not okay all
right there's training happening at the
lower levels
it's not okay okay we didn't tell you to
do that all right we said
and that needs to be said very very
clearly so a couple officers want to
come on here
centcom said no and talk about the
calamity which is our pull out of
afghanistan
they said no to that but if you want to
hop on with anderson cooper and talk
about
your sexuality that gets the green light
and praise unbelievable
exactly dan crenshaw thank you very much
for joining us today
thank you